il y a toujours
mes chers collègues
madame la Présidente
nous avons le plaisir aujourd'hui de
recevoir Madame lors de la Rodière
présidente depuis désormais deux ans le
temps passe vite de l'Autorité de
régulation des communications
électroniques des postes et de la
distribution de la presse vous êtes
accompagné à la fois par
Madame alors attendez Monsieur le
Directeur Général Adjoint c'est ça voilà
merci ainsi que des membres du collège
de la recette voilà et votre cabinet
soyez tous les bienvenus madame la
Présidente ne vous avions auditionné la
dernière fois le 20 janvier 2021 dans le
cadre de la procédure de nomination qui
est prévue à l'article 13 de la
Constitution et si nous avons souhaité
effectuer un premier bilan d'étape avec
vous c'est parce qu'en deux ans le
contexte a beaucoup changé dans les
secteurs des postes et des
télécommunications alors disons-le un
peu cash isolé un peu tout de suite le
contexte actuel n'est pas à l'apaisement
mais j'utiliserai trois mots plutôt à la
gacement à l'inquiétude et parfois
je pense premièrement à l'agacement des
habitants et des élus qui portent
désormais plainte contre les opérateurs
de télécommunication raison des retards
en raison des incidents des
dysfonctionnements répétés dans le
déploiement de la fibre forcé de
cadenacer des armoires de raccordement
de prendre des arrêtés contraignants les
opérateurs
contraint pardon les opérateurs à
partager leur calendrier d'intervention
et les techniciens s'enregistrer même au
commissariat voire même de s'adresser
directement à l'autorité que vous
présentez que vous présidez les élus
sont devenus des régulateurs du
quotidien d'un secteur qui aux yeux de
beaucoup s'apparente aujourd'hui une
sorte de forme de Far West sans shérif
face à cette situation l'autorité que
vous présidez à publier en novembre
dernier un nouveau plan d'action pour
améliorer la qualité de l'exploitation
des réseaux en fibres optique dont
l'État notamment en Île-de-France savait
moins bon que dans les autres régions
selon la dernière an prise de terrain
que vous avez mené quels sont donc
madame la Présidente les engagements
pris par les opérateurs pour améliorer
la qualité des raccordements à la fibre
et de quelle façon la recette les
contrôles et le cas échéant les met en
demeure de ce conformer à leurs
obligations et de respecter leur nouveau
engagements alors que la demande
d'autorité de sanction et d'annonce de
mesure forte se fait de plus en plus
pressante vous défendez madame la
Présidente un modèle de régulation
d'abord centré sur la concertation mon
caractère me mènerait au même
conclusions entre dialogue et sanctions
comment trouver le bon équilibre afin de
permettre à la recette d'exercer
pleinement les fonctions qui lui sont
attribuées par la loi je pense aussi à
l'agacement des abonnés qui ont ces
débuts d'années marqués par une
inflation qui pourrait attendre 7% voit
le prix de leur forfait mobile augmenter
de quelques euros par mois alors certes
la France grâce à une intensité
concurrentielle forte dispose de prix
parmi les plus bas d'Europe peut-être
même par les pays du monde les plus bas
15 euros 70 en moyenne pour un forfait
mobile 33 euros en moyenne pour un
abonnement Internet fixe mais là aussi
lorsque les prix augmentent que la
qualité de service n'est pas au
rendez-vous et que les déceptions
d'usage sont nombreuses les attentes
sont fortes vis-à-vis du régulateur à
l'agacement s'agit aussi l'inquiétude je
le disais tout à l'heure inquiétude des
élus et des habitants qui sont concernés
par les fermetures du réseau cuivre
d'ici 2025 il est estimé que 670 000
foyers ne disposeront pas de la fibre
optique en raison de la complexité de
leur raccordement au réseau alors même
que l'ARCEP a fixé un critère de 100% de
locaux raccordables à la fibre optique
sur le territoire d'une commune pour
pouvoir fermer le réseau cuivre dont
orange et l'opérateur d'infrastructures
uniques et historique concrètement
qu'est-ce que cela signifie ce que les
personnes seront écartées de l'accès à
la fibre ou est-ce que Orange devra
prolonger temporairement et localement
l'accès à son réseau cuivre afin de
respecter ce critère à l'inquiétude ça
s'ajoute ensuite l'offensive qui est
d'abord celle des opérateurs lors de son
audition remarquée devant notre
commission le 30 novembre dernier madame
Christelle edmann directrice générale
d'Orange a annoncé préparer dit-elle de
lourds contentieux contre la recette à
propos de l'encadrement contesté des
tarifs de dégroupage une annonce très
médiatisée qui ne vous a certainement
pas échappé et qui témoignent des
divisions qui agitent le secteur dans ce
contexte nous sommes impatients de
bénéficier donc de vos éclairages est-ce
qu'une hausse est tarif de découpage
vous paraît justifier sinon comment
assurer une juste régulation du secteur
des télécommunications sans favoriser ou
défavoriser un opérateur plutôt qu'un
autre si la concurrence dans le secteur
des télécommunications mobilisent
aujourd'hui toute notre attention il y a
un dernier sujet sur lequel je
souhaiterais vous interroger depuis le
1er janvier 2023 la poste commercialise
un nouveau catalogue de service d'envoi
postaux qui relève du service universel
postal cette réforme se matérialise
notamment par la suppression du timbre
rouge et l'optimisation par
l'expérimentation sur 68 sites de
tournée de distribution du courrier par
les facteurs nous auditionnerons
prochainement Philippe Val le PDG de la
Poste mais je souhaiterais savoir si la
recette est prononcée sur cette réforme
en tant que président de l'Autorité
chargée de faire respecter les
obligations de service public et un
combat à la poste pensez vous que nous
sommes en train d'assister à une
réduction déguisée de ce service
universel postal ou s'agit-il plutôt de
mesures d'optimisation rendu nécessaire
par l'évolution des usages voilà le menu
est grand et je suis sûr que vous aurez
beaucoup de questions tout à l'heure par
l'ensemble de nos collègues madame la
Présidente je vous laisse la parole
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs merci de votre
accueil ce matin je suis venue comme
vous l'avez dit accompagné de deux
membres du collège de la recette ce
matin bayabakache professeur en sciences
économique et Emmanuel Gabla ingénieur
général des mines vous connaissez aussi
peut-être ma conseillère Virginie Mathot
et le directeur adjoint de l'ARCEP
Olivier corollaire pour rebondir sur vos
propos introductifs madame la Présidente
je vais d'abord évoquer finalement le
dernier point que vous soulevez qui est
celui de la poste
comme vous le savez
la post fait face à une baisse des du
courrier de son activité historique et
la baisse du courrier a coûté 600
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires à
la poste en 2021
et les prévisions sont les mêmes pour
2022 dans ce contexte l'équilibre
économique du service universel postal
est remis en cause et le Parlement nous
a confié d'ailleurs une nouvelle mission
dans la loi de finances pour 2022 celle
d'évaluer le coup net du service
universel postal avec un coût que nous
avons estimé à 1,6 milliards d'euros et
inversement de l'État à la poste égal à
520 millions d'euros au titre de l'année
2021 nous avons pu ainsi vérifier
l'absence de surcompensation nous avons
aussi effectivement rendu des avis sur
la nouvelle gamme des services inclus
dans le service universel et lancé par
la poste au 1er janvier 2023 l'objectif
est bien une réduction des coûts de la
mission de service universel vous voyez
la différence entre le versement de
l'État et le coût estimé préalablement à
ces mesures mais dans nos nous avons
demandé à la poste de
vérifier l'accompagnement qui serait
fait sur le lancement de cette nouvelle
gamme auprès des Français
nous avons aussi demandé à ce que une
évaluation du soir remise de cette
nouvelle cam régulièrement il est bien
sûr trop tôt aujourd'hui pour faire une
évaluation puisque cela a été lancé il y
a un mois et parallèlement nous
veillerons comme comme nous le faisons
de toute façon à ce que la Poste
respecte l'ensemble des obligations de
la mission de service universel postale
qui est lui attribué au titre de la loi
concernant les enjeux de la régulation
du secteur des télécommunications je
vous promets propose quand même de
commencer par les bonnes nouvelles
malgré un tableau qui est celui que vous
attribez dressé qui est et qui réaliste
c'est toutes les situations que vous
avez cité ce sont des constats nous nous
avons aussi mais il y a quand même des
bonnes nouvelles alors nous nous privons
pas pendant la crise sanitaire le
secteur a bien résisté les réseaux ont
été massivement sollicités et on fait
preuve de résilience la crise n'a pas
freiné les investissements des
opérateurs au contraire puisqu'ils ont
investi plus de 40 milliards d'euros ces
trois dernières années pour apporter une
meilleure connectivité fixe et mobile
aux Français sans compter l'intervention
publique de l'État et des collectivités
je tiens à saluer d'abord bien
évidemment pour salut l'engagement des
opérateurs et aussi des collectivités
dans cet objectif mais je souhaite aussi
rappeler que c'est le fruit d'un choix
de régulation
résolument tourné vers l'investissement
et qui place l'intérêt des utilisateurs
au cœur de ces objectifs nos choix de
régulation
offrent la stabilité et la présidité
dont les acteurs économiques ont besoin
pour investir il s'inscrivent aussi dans
un temps long celui des investissements
dans les infrastructures et répondent
aux enjeux d'aménagement numérique du
territoire porté par les politiques
publiques et je dirais porté par les
élus que vous êtes aussi sans
méconnaître les difficultés économiques
conjoncturelles cela nécessite de voir
loin de penser aux équilibres de tous
les acteurs opérateurs historiques
opérateur d'infrastructures fibres
opérateur commerciaux collectivités
aussi et de mettre au coeur de notre
action l'intérêt des utilisateurs
particuliers et entreprises et ceux-ci
dans tous les territoires j'y suis
particulièrement attentive alors quels
sont les résultats aujourd'hui et quels
sont les enjeux à venir les résultats
commen parle mobile le New Deal lancé en
juillet 2018 porte ses fruits et
largement publicité ce changement de
paradigme dans l'attribution des
fréquences sous l'impulsion politique
des élus a été l'engagement de tous
gouvernement et la recette pour la
conception opérateur bien sûr pour le
travail collectif et constructif réalisé
collectivités dans le choix des zones à
couvrir harcèle pour le contrôle des
applications des obligations cela
fonctionne bien je pense naturellement
au dispositif de couverture ciblée avec
déjà 1786 choisi par les collectivités
donc 84 94%
quadriopérateurs qui ont été mis en
service au 30 septembre 2022
mais le dispositif de course d'ouverture
ciblées n'est pas la seule obligation du
New Deal la généralisation de la 4G en
est une autre à la même date selon les
opérateurs de 97,5 à 99% des sites
français ont la 4G de même les quatre
opérateurs avaient l'obligation de
fournir alors client une solution
d'appel sur Wi-Fi c'est fait et très
utile pour améliorer la couverture à
l'intérieur des bâtiments ayant un accès
Internet et du wifi d'autres obligations
sont aussi associées au New Deal qui
concourent également à l'amélioration de
la couverture mobile sur les territoires
l'obligation de couverture des axes
routiers prioritaires ou encore
l'exigence de qualité de sa vie dans les
obligations générales des opérateurs et
enfin grâce aux objectifs de déploiement
de la 4G fixe 1000 sites vont permettre
une montée en débit sur certaines zones
où la fibre n'est pas encore déployée
pour finir avec le mobile après les
inquiétudes citoyennes et politiques en
2020 et 2021 autour du lancement de la
5G dans la bande de fréquence 3,5 GHz
les travaux de concertation et de débats
organisés par les collectivités dans
lequel d'ailleurs la recette a été
régulièrement impliqué ont permis
d'apaiser la situation et la 5G se
déploie actuellement dans toutes les
agglomérations ainsi que progressivement
dans les villes moyennes
parallèlement la fibre est devenue le
réseau d'accès à internet de référence
pour les Français
puisqu'en 2022 la barre des 50% des
abonnements Internet audiby et très haut
débit a été franchi et le nombre de
locaux rendus raccordable à la Free à la
fibre approche désormais les 80%. on
peut là aussi dire que le plan France
trait au débit est un succès collectif
tant pour le rythme de déploiement que
pour la maîtrise des dépenses publiques
et maintenant pour le succès commercial
c'est d'ailleurs ce que souligne le
récent rapport de France stratégie en
mettant en avant plusieurs facteurs clés
de succès la stabilité dans le cadre
dans le temps du cadre réglementaire mis
en place dès 2009 qui a apporté une
prévisibilité essentielle pour les
investisseurs privés et publics et la
gouvernance du plan France très haut
débit qui est associé tout le monde
gouvernement accepte parlementaire
collectivité opérateur
un peu comme comme dans le cas du New
Deal même si le contexte est différent
l'implication de tous dans un objectif
commun majeur autour d'un enjeu de
politique publique qui est d'apporter
une connectivité fixe à très haut débit
à chaque Français à chaque entreprise
permet d'obtenir des résultats
ce succès du plan France très haut débit
ce sont des efforts des efforts
industriels et humains tout à fait
remarquable de la part des opérateurs et
des collectivités mais je veux aussi
saluer l'ensemble des hommes et des
femmes qui chaque jour
œuvrent sur le terrain au déploiement
des réseaux
dans ce contexte quels sont les enjeux
et qu'elles sont nos propriétés
priorités de régulation pour les années
à venir
l'enjeu d'avoir une bonne qualité des
réseaux fixes et mobiles disponible
partout à tarif abordable demeure bien
sûr la première priorité de la
régulation et nous y avons associé
l'enjeu d'avoir un numérique durable
pour répondre à ces enjeux quelles sont
nos priorités
elles sont tournées vers la satisfaction
des utilisateurs qu'il s'agisse de
l'amélioration de la qualité des
raccordements fibres et vous avez évoqué
la situation actuelle j'y reviendrai de
la poursuite des déploiements fibres de
la fermeture du réseau cuivre et du
maintien de la qualité de service du
réseau jusqu'à sa fermeture ou encore de
la prise en compte dans nos actions de
régulation de l'impact environnemental
du numérique je vous propose d'aborder
chacune de ces priorités en commençant
par la qualité de service sur la fibre
elle a été sans doute ma première
priorité lorsque j'ai été nommée il y a
deux ans comme présidente de larsep tout
le monde se félicitait alors du volume
des déploiements qui atteignait des
niveaux records avec près de 6 millions
de nouveaux locaux rendus raccordables à
la fibre en 2020
mais les situations invraisemblables et
inacceptables vécues par nos concitoyens
le nombre d'alerte reçus d'élus
confrontés à ces situations dans leur
commune témoignages que vous recevez
tout aussi en tant que parlementaire
m'ont conduit à prioriser les travaux
sur ce sujet en 2021 les opérateurs
n'avaient toujours pas mis en place les
processus de contrôle ni les outils
permettant de tracer les interventions
effectuées sur les réseaux et
d'identifier les responsables des
malfaçons et des dégradations sur leur
réseau ils étaient aussi dans un certain
déni de l'importance du sujet
aujourd'hui les travaux ont avancés
d'une part grâce aux indicateurs
collectés depuis avril le 2021 l'ARCEP a
identifié que certains réseaux
concentraient les incidents cela
concerne 2% des lignes fibres sur
quelques réseaux principalement en
Île-de-France comme l'avait mentionné
les opérateurs concernés ont notifié à
larcep des plans de reprise de leur
réseau ainsi altitude à présenter fin
septembre 2022 un plan de reprise pour
les réseaux concernés ce sont les
réseaux ex-covages exutor dans l'Essonne
et dans le Calvados se déroulant jusqu'à
mi-2023 et XP fibre a présenté mi
novembre 2022 un plan de reprise pour
certains de ses réseaux les plus
dégradés
le suivi de ces plans de reprise afin de
veiller au respect par les opérateurs
des engagements pris
d'autre part à la demande de larsep et
du gouvernement la filière a remis un
plan d'action pour améliorer la qualité
des réseaux fibres en septembre dernier
je reconnais le travail collectif
réalisé sur ce sujet
larsep en assure un suivi mensuel et
nous serons particulièrement vigilants
sur l'exécution de ce plan permettant
notamment la mise en place d'un réel
contrôle des opérations réalisées par
les agents d'intervention sur le terrain
et ainsi éviter les débranchements
sauvages mais aussi un engagement avoir
des agents qualifiés et formés pour
assurer les interventions que ce soit
chez les clients ou sur les réseaux
ce point ce plan doit conduire partout
sur tous les réseaux à une amélioration
des pratiques et à la remise en état des
infrastructures dégradées au fil de
l'eau
cet enjeu de qualité de service tout
paraît important à plusieurs titres
d'abord parce qu'il est pas acceptable
que la promesse technologique et les
investissements massifs réalisés face
l'objet de tant de déception parce qu'il
est pas acceptable d'avoir des
situations comme celles vivent celles
que vivent nos concitoyens mais aussi
parce que cet enjeu nous apparaît
d'autant plus important dans la
perspective de la fermeture du réseau
cuve par Orange
il faut pouvoir compter sur un réseau
fibre bien construit et bien exploiter
pour permettre et réussir la
substitution du réseau cuivre par cette
nouvelle infrastructure tout comme il
faut que la qualité de service du réseau
cuivre se maintiennent
jusqu'à sa fermeture
j'allais dire s'améliore c'est essentiel
mais ce n'est pas le seul préalable pour
vouloir fermer le réseau cuivre et c'est
un enjeu et un projet structurant pour
la filière il faut aussi que les
déploiements des réseaux en fibres
optique soient terminés or nous
constatons depuis quelques mois que même
si le volume global reste élevé du fait
des déploiements en zone d'initiative
publique notamment il ralentit de façon
très inquiétante dans les zones moins
denses d'initiatives privées et dans les
zones très denses
le ralentissement des déploiements
d'orange en zone ami et problématique
d'abord car il prive certains de nos
concitoyens du bénéfice de la fibre bien
évidemment et rappelons à cet égard
qu'il s'agit d'engagement librement
consenti par les opérateurs concernés
certains d'entre vous s'en souviennent
ce choix d'ailleurs été fait à
l'encontre de la volonté de certaines
collectivités de déployer sur ces zones
ensuite il est aussi problématique car
il fragilise la trajectoire de fermeture
du réseau cuivre
j'insiste il est pas responsable il
n'est pas responsable d'avoir comme
stratégie de fermer le réseau cuivre et
en même temps d'arrêter les déploiements
de la fibre en zone ami ou en zone très
dense
j'espère que le plan stratégique qui
sera présenté par la nouvelle
gouvernance d'orange à la mi-favier sera
l'octation de rectifier le tir
alors comment faire de ce plan de
fermeture du cuivre à succès
d'abord par une excellente gouvernance
et une parfaite concertation le succès
du plan reposera dans la mise effective
par Orange d'une gouvernance associant
réellement toutes les parties prenantes
et dans un esprit de parfaite
concertation avec l'opérateur
d'infrastructure de la zone bien sûr
mais aussi avec tous les opérateurs
commerciaux et les collectivités
concernées
je regrette qu'au orange ne s'appuie pas
davantage sur les propositions faites
par les collectivités concernant les
communes devant faire l'objet des
premières fermetures il paraît
préférable en effet de commencer par les
communes et les élus les plus motivées
cela faciliterait grandement les
opérations
de plus orange doit beaucoup plus
partager toutes les informations dont il
disposent notamment celles permettant de
réconcilier les adresses de présence du
réseau cuivre avec celle du réseau fibre
de l'opérateur d'infrastructures et ceci
afin de permettre une substitution des
deux réseaux
enfin il faut il faut veiller à ce
qu'une communication neutre et
rassurante soit assurée auprès des
Français concernés par la fermeture du
réseau cuivre
sur le marché entreprise le projet de
fermeture du réseau cuivre est aussi
stratégique tant de nombreuses
entreprises en sont encore dépendantes
la bascule du cuivre vers la fibre et
donc l'occasion de développer la
concurrence sur ce marché
ambition que porte la recette depuis
plusieurs années nous pourrons y revenir
à l'occasion des questions si vous le
souhaitez
dernier point que je voulais aborder
dans mon propos liminaires mais non des
moindres la prise en compte des enjeux
environnementaux du numérique
et comme le mentionne le rapport du
Sénat réalisé en 2021
l'empreinte carbone du numérique
représente 2% de l'empreinte totale en
France cela peut paraître peu mais sa
croissance est exponentielle du fait de
la multiplication des usages du
numérique et des terminaux connectés il
nous paraît donc essentiel que le
secteur du numérique qui peut par des
services innovants contribuent à porter
des solutions face aux enjeux
climatiques ne s'exonère pas pour autant
des efforts à faire pour réduire
lui-même son empreinte
c'est pour cela que nous avons ouvert un
nouveau chapitre de la régulation avec
la prise en compte des enjeux
environnementaux du numérique grâce à la
proposition de loi du Sénat d'ailleurs
de Patrick chaise la loi reine 2 votée
en décembre 2021 notre collègue donné
environnementale et désormais élargi
à l'ensemble des acteurs du numérique
notre pouvoir de collecte est élargi à
l'ensemble des acteurs du numérique et
viendra progressivement enrichir
l'enquête annuelle pour un numérique
soutenable ces résultats vont donner une
vision chiffrée inédite de l'empreinte
environnementale du numérique nous
poursuivons quatre objectifs le premier
à former les citoyens les acteurs
publics et l'ensemble des parties
prenantes sur les impacts
environnementaux du secteur le deuxième
c'est d'identifier les activités des
acteurs économiques susceptibles d'avoir
un impact sur l'environnement n'a pas
positif sur l'environnement le troisième
c'est inciter les acteurs à cibler leurs
actions vers les mesures les plus
efficaces en matière d'impact
et puis le dernier c'est suivre
l'évolution de ces indicateurs dans le
temps permettant d'apprécier les effets
des actions de protection de
l'environnement mise en place par les
entreprises et de fournir des éléments
pertinents pour l'évaluation des
politiques publiques sur le numérique et
l'environnement
je veux finir mes propos liminaires en
vous assurant de l'engagement de
l'ensemble des membres du collège de
tous les arts et les arts sepiants de
l'équipe de direction à défendre les
objectifs d'intérêt général et les
priorités politiques que vous nous fixez
par la loi sur l'ensemble des secteurs
que nous régulons avec en ligne de mire
en boussole la satisfaction des
utilisateurs je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
alors il y a de très très nombreuses
questions j'ai commencé par une
intervention de Patrick chaise puis
Anne-Catherine Loisier
merci madame la présidente madame la
Présidente
du collège mes chers collègues
je suis tout d'abord ravi mais à la
présidente de pouvoir vous auditionner
quelques semaines après avoir entendu
madame Christelle Henneman directrice
générale du groupe Orange
ce n'est pas trahir un secret que
d'avouer que l'intérêt de votre audition
a été renforcée par les propos tenus
lors de cet échange
mon questionnement se décomposera en
trois thèmes le dégroupage la qualité de
service du réseau cuivre et enfin le
déploiement de la fibre optique
concernant le découpage madame Hennemann
a indiqué que entre le découpage et le
génie civil si le régulateur ne prend
pas les décisions qui s'imposent ce sont
228 millions d'euros de recettes
essentielles pour maintenir
l'infrastructure que nous ne percevons
pas je la cite et qui resteront dans les
caisses des opérateurs commerciaux pour
vous donner une illustration concrète
cela correspond à accueillir
gratuitement l'un des trois grands
opérateurs commerciaux
quel est votre réaction à ce propos
une façon de répondre pourrait être
d'augmenter très significativement le
tarif du dégroupage de sorte que les
opérateurs soient incités économiquement
à migrer leurs clients vers la fibre
dans l'esprit de la création de la zone
fibrée créée dans le cadre de la loi
Macron
sur la qualité de service du réseau
cuivre madame indiqué la meilleure façon
d'améliorer la qualité de service du
cuivre c'est de fermer le réseau
rappelant qu'il était urgent de traiter
l'équation économique du réseau cuivre
car il y a derrière cette équation le
sujet essentiel de la qualité de service
du cuivre encore primordial pour
quelques années
pouvez-vous nous dire comment ça se
passe ailleurs en Europe plus
particulièrement quelles obligations de
qualité de service pèsent sur les offres
de gros cuivre des opérateurs
historiques dans nos pays voisins tels
que l'Allemagne l'Espagne ou l'Italie
est-il soutenable de maintenir des
obligations exigeantes de qualité de
service pour le réseau cuivre d'orange
dans les conditions actuelles de prix
enfin concernant les obligations sur les
réseaux fibres optiques elle a annoncé
qu'elle était étonnée face au menaces de
sanctions pour non-respects des
engagements l3313 elle a également
précisé que la France était le pays le
plus fibré d'Europe avec plus de 130% de
locaux éligibles à la fibre entre 2007
2017 pardon et 2022 et dans les
territoires les moins denses
comment réagissez-vous à ses propos quel
est votre interprétation sur les
engagements pris par les opérateurs
comment et surtout pourront-ils être
atteints quels sont vos actions pour
Orange mais aussi pour les autres
opérateurs et comment se passe les
déploiements et les contrôles de fibre
optique dans les autres pays comparables
je vous remercie
si madame la Présidente merci beaucoup
de votre présence alors peut-être juste
pour rebondir sur les compléter les
thèmes évoqués par par mon collègue
Patrick moi j'ai une éternelle question
en matière de qualité des services c'est
quand même le fonctionnement des comités
cuivre je m'évertis à essayer d'y
participer depuis des mois et je n'y
arrive pas alors je voilà je pense que
si les comités que vous savez vous en
avez vous l'avez peu à évoqué en parlant
de ce manque de concertation et de
transparence et d'informations sur les
territoires donc effectivement je pense
qu'en tout cas si si les élus pouvaient
être davantage associé à la fermeture
des réseaux cuits sur leur territoire et
avoir un éclairage plus précis ça
contribuerait en tout cas à certainement
une plus grande efficacité une petite
question sur le financement des réseaux
qui a été effectivement également évoqué
lors de notre audition de même la
directrice générale d'orange c'est le
financement des réseaux regarde
notamment de l'évolution le trafic et là
la contribution éventuelle donc des
grandes plateformes que pensez-vous en
fait de cette de ce dispositif en tout
cas d'une nouvelle réglementation qui
permettrait ainsi d'instaurer peut-être
un mécanisme de compensation des coûts
et des investissements majeurs qui sont
réalisés et qui seront encore à réaliser
et puis enfin un dernier sujet qui me
tient aussi à coeur il s'agit en fait de
l'accès aux infrastructures qui sont
détenus par les sociétés d'autoroute ou
les sociétés fervières ça fait un petit
moment que je travaille sur ce sujet
avec les opérateurs alternatifs qui
m'ont souligné en fait l'opacité d'accès
assez réseau notamment en matière de
pratique tarifaire donc vous êtes vous
penché sur ce sujet puisque les réseaux
dont dispose les sociétés routières sont
sont importants sur l'ensemble du
territoire et pourrait notamment être
des supports en matière d'accès pour les
entreprises et le maillage en tout cas
économique de notre territoire donc
avez-vous un projet en matière de
régulation de ces politiques tarifaires
sur les réseaux des concessionnaires
merci très bien merci beaucoup je vais
vous proposer madame la Présidente de
répondre à nos deux rapporteurs et puis
ensuite je prendrai les questions
supplémentaires
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
merci pour vos questions ça me permet de
répondre à des sujets qui ont été
soulevés à plusieurs reprises et donc je
vous en remercie alors sur le tarif du
dégroupage orange nous a saisi
mi-octobre 2022 d'une demande de
révision des tarifs de découpage nous
avons examiné bien évidemment cette
demande et avons trouvé légitime la
demande faite sur la révision de la
partie fixe de la partie liée à l'hyper
fixe dans le tarif du dégroupage
nous avons donc mis en consultation
publique
ça devait être juste avant Noël une
proposition de révision sur ce point
afin de recueillir naturellement la vie
de l'ensemble des parties prenantes
orange a décidé néanmoins de contester
devant le Conseil d'État le tarif du
dégroupage fixé par l'analyse de marché
2020 de décembre 2020 ce contentieux en
cours ne me permet pas d'être très
bavarde aujourd'hui
néanmoins c'est peut-être
utile d'avoir en tête qu'il y a encore
15 millions de lignes cuivre active en
France ce qui reste présente deux
milliards d'euros de revenus annuels
pour pour Orange au tarif du dégroupage
actuel
mais pour prendre le sujet plus
globalement et pour répondre aussi à une
question que vous avez soulevée madame
la Présidente l'économie de la filière
c'est vrai aujourd'hui même si les
opérateurs montent une capacité
d'adaptation et une grande résilience
la crise énergétique et l'inflation des
récupères ont des répercussions sur des
postes de coûts variés et pour autant le
marché des services de télécommunication
de masse est un marché nature qui en
même temps nécessite toujours de lourds
investissement or les revenus ne suivent
pas nécessairement les opérateurs
peinent à trouver des relations des
relais de croissance et donc c'est vrai
que l'équation économique actuelle du
secteur n'est pas évidente mais c'est
vrai pour Orange c'est vrai aussi pour
tous les autres opérateurs
sur la qualité de service du réseau
cuivre
certains territoires n'auront pas la
fibre avant encore quelques années donc
oui le maintien de d'un réseau de cuivre
de qualité dans le contexte de la
transition cuivre est indispensable et
nous n'avons aucun élément aujourd'hui
qui nous laisse penser qu'au range ne
peut pas respecter ses obligations de QS
compte tenu des revenus qu'ils tirent
actuellement de son réseau
les problèmes de qualité de service du
cuivre ne sont pas nouveaux et vous le
savez ils sont pas apparus avec le
village du réseau cuivre en 2017 une
baisse de la qualité de sa vie s'est
constatée sur les indicateurs de qualité
de service que nous suivons et ce qui a
conduit la recette la formation RDPI de
la recette à mettre en dehors orange de
respecter ses obligations de qualité de
service la situation c'est un meilleur
élevage légèrement avant de se
redégrader de nouveau en 2020
donc nous avons prolongé l'encadrement
de la qualité de service du réseau
cuivre en précisant des seuils chiffrés
à respecter par Orange de naturation
assuré un accès effectif au réseau de
boucles locales cuivre en 2021 sous la
pression des élus du gouvernement et de
la recette un plan cuivre a été mis en
place par le gouvernement avec
l'opérateur historique orange c'est à
cette occasion que les comités cuivre
ont été
créés
pas nécessairement dans tous les
départements mais qu'une circulaire du
Premier ministre a demandé au préfet de
créer ces comités de suivi cuivre dans
certains départements nous avons la
formation que ça marche c'est efficace
ça permet une concertation ça permet
aussi d'avoir certains préfets ont
traite l'ensemble des sujets c'est à
dire que ils ont d'abord une première
partie de la Réunion il y a le New Deal
une deuxième partie où on va regarder
les déploiements de la fibre et puis une
troisième partie mais sans les
opérateurs alternatifs ou il parle du
cuivre donc je pense que c'est variable
d'un département à l'autre et peut-être
que un point avec la NCT sur ce sujet
serait le bon organisme d'État
pour pour cela
alors pour nous c'est indispensable de
pouvoir compter jusqu'en 2030 sur un
réseau cuivre qui tient la route et donc
il faut que partout c'est possible
orange et la positive possibilité réelle
de fermer son réseau cuivre là où les
réseaux FTTH peuvent être effectivement
si substituer et comme cela orange
pourra concentrer ses efforts et ses
moyens là où le réseau cuivre reste
nécessaire concernant la comparaison
européenne alors nous avons fait un
benchmark avec quelques pays européens
ce que vous citez monsieur le sénateur
et la Suède aussi Allemagne Espagne
Italie Suède notamment pour voir comment
il prenait et comment les autorités de
régulation avaient
[Musique]
avait encadré les projets de fermeture
des réseaux cuve dans ces pays les
situations sont très variables je dirais
que l'Espagne et la Suède sont très
avancées le projet de fermeture du
réseau cuivre en Espagne et en Suède de
94 à 96% des locaux sont fibrés mais
pour autant il y a toujours pour les
parties du réseau cuivre qui reste des
indicateurs de qualité de service qui
sont imposées à ces opérateurs
concernant les deux autres pays
Allemagne Italie ils sont beaucoup moins
engagés que la France ou ses autres pays
dans le dans le déploiement de la fibre
ou dans le plan de fermeture du réseau
cuivre et il existe bien évidemment des
indicateurs de qualité de service et des
obligations de qualité de service
aux opérateurs donc ça montre en fait
que
dans tous les pays l'enjeu de qualité de
maintenir la qualité de service sur le
réseau cuivre est importante jusqu'à sa
fermeture
pas la qualité de service pour parler ah
non les obligations de de fibre optique
pardon c'est plus le déploiement et
votre marque monsieur le sénateur sur
l'étonnement de d'orange
pour nous les engagements pris doivent
être respectés le rôle du régulateur
c'est justement de les faire respecter
donc je suis étonnée moi même de
l'étonnement d'orange sur le fait que
nous avons mis en demeure orange de
respecter les engageants qu'ils ont pris
et sur le fait finalement que le
régulateur joue son rôle
orange comptait cette décision de mise
en demeure notamment considérant avoir
pris un engagement sur un volume de
ligne au sens d'indicateurs statistique
Insee daté a déployé et l'attaquer donc
ils ont attaqué notre mise en demeure
devant le Conseil d'État nous
considérons que la lecture des
engagements d'orange ne laisse aucun
doute quant à la nature réelle de
l'engagement il s'agit d'un engagement
de couverture d'une liste de commune qui
doit être complète à une date donnée
c'est d'ailleurs ainsi
que l'on
et d'ailleurs c'est ainsi à mon avis que
le comprenne toutes les collectivités en
zone amie
pour être exhaustif sur les mises en
demeure et juste simplement rappeler que
nous avons aussi mis en demeure
sa voix connectée donc c'est XP fibre de
respecter ses obligations dans le cadre
des obligations zonamelles et aussi SFR
dans la Nièvre donc Nièvre numérique de
respecter ses obligations dans la zone
Amel
vous m'avez posé la question madame la
sénatrice Loisier du
financement des réseaux de ce qui est
communément appelé le faire cher alors
simplement dire que ce débat date pas
d'aujourd'hui et il a plus de 10 ans et
pour l'instant force de constater que
les réseaux se sont adaptés à cette
croissance de trafic et la neutralité
d'Internet a été préservée
le premier point sur lequel je souhaite
insister et que tout débat sur le fer
cher doit exclure la remise en cause du
règlement d'Internet ouvert
principe fondamental pour l'innovation
et la liberté de communication mais
c'est important que le régulateur vous
le dise et vous disent que nous y sommes
très attachés une fois ceci posé je
trouve à titre personnel le débat
légitime sur la responsabilisation des
gafams sur l'augmentation du trafic sur
les réseaux certains défendent que seuls
les clients des opérateurs seraient
responsables car c'est eux seuls qui
décide de la façon d'utiliser leur accès
internet mais c'est aussi oublié que le
modèle économique de ces grands
fournisseurs de contenus reposent sur
l'économie de l'attention générant
toujours plus de vidéos
auto-activées toujours plus de
consommation de bande passante une
responsabilisation de ces acteurs sur
l'augmentation continue des volumes de
données sur internet me paraît à titre
personnel intéressantes les
responsabiliser par exemple sur l'impact
environnemental de l'exposition
l'explosion des usages numériques ou
encore les responsabiliser aussi sur le
Benoît besoin en financement public pour
la construction des réseaux très haut
débit dans les territoires non rentables
je
précise bien les les choses
peut-être une réflexion et c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui a décidé de faire la
Commission européenne je crois que
l'annonce de la grande consultation
publique est prévue pour le 10 février
prochain sur ces enjeux
d'économie dans le secteur des
télécommunications
les accès infrastructures
autoroutes et autres
au détenteur d'infrastructures c'est un
point qui nous est remonté mais pour
pouvoir prendre aller plus loin en fait
dans la régulation il serait utile que
les opérateurs qui se plaignent d'avoir
des difficultés d'accès à ces
infrastructures de génie civil nous en
fasse part sous forme d'un règlement de
différents pour qu'on puisse après à
partir de ce règlement de différents
instruire le dossier et et fixé en fait
déjà arbitré entre les deux parties qui
nous c'est entre la partie qui nous
saisit avec
les difficultés qui rencontrent et en
général les règlements de différents
conduisent souvent à ce que nos
décisions face au fils de nouvelles
normes sur un marché
très bien donc nous allons maintenant
prendre l'ensemble des questions Fabien
gay et ensuite Evelyne Renaud garabée
une question simple il y a quelque chose
qui a fait beaucoup parler c'est je suis
là
au fond de la classe à gauche
tout à fait
non il y a quelque chose qui a fait
beaucoup parler c'est la disparition du
timbre rouge et ça revient un peu à la
question que vous a posé en introduction
madame la Présidente ça peut se
comprendre parce qu'il y a une question
de diminution du courrier qui est en
fait mais il y a une mission d'égalité
républicaine et d'une promesse
républicaine c'est j'envoie du courrier
ou que je sois et le lendemain ou que
l'on soit on le recevait et la
disparition du timbre rouge c'est ça bon
je parle pas du remplacement du fait de
l'e-mail payant un euro 49 bon tout ça
tout le monde comprend bien que c'est
une vaste blague mais lorsque nous nous
avons dénoncé ça c'était la question
légale et surtout de se dire que chaque
jour
le facteur ou la factrice allait passer
et c'est aussi du lien social dans
beaucoup de territoire et pas que dans
des territoires ruraux mais aujourd'hui
depuis 15 ans
c'est la tournée des facteurs et des
factrices qui c'est étendues les hommes
et les femmes d'ailleurs ne quitter
travail ne font pas la même tournée du
jour au lendemain donc y compris les
citoyens les citoyens de les connaissent
plus bon bref et de ça arrive une
deuxième décision de la poste qui est de
dire on va expérimenter et on sait ce
que ça veut dire l'expérimentation la
tournée un jour sur deux
bon et là je vous interroge sur une
autre mission de la recette vous n'avez
pas encore évoqué celle de la
distribution de la presse je viens pas
de la distribution de la presse par MLP
et puis France messagerie j'aurais
beaucoup de choses à dire mais je vais
me mettre un pas de côté mais par contre
pour les abonnés
qui doivent recevoir leur journaux
chaque jour il va falloir m'expliquer
dans les territoires d'expérimentation
comment ceci va fonctionner et je
rappelle que la distribution de la
presse c'est une question d'égalité à
républicaine mais surtout démocratique
garantie par notre Constitution et la
poste elle reçoit un dédommagement pour
ça et c'est bien normal parce que c'est
évidemment du travail et donc on
explique que ceci ne va plus être fait
par la poste et qu'il faudra donc penser
par des porteurs privés porteurs privés
qui évidemment seront beaucoup plus cher
pour les abonnés et pour les éditeurs de
presse donc comme vous êtes
garante aussi de cette nouvelle mission
je voulais avoir votre avis sur cette
question je vous remercie
oui merci Madame présidente madame la
Présidente entre 2012 et 2022 le nombre
d'internautes a doublé et ils sont
aujourd'hui environ 3 milliards dans le
monde ainsi si internet était un pays il
serait le troisième consommateur
d'électricité après
la Chine et les États-Unis
l'immatérialité du secteur ne doit pas
masquer cette surconsommation et ce coût
environnemental que son usage représente
depuis quelques années lacep s'intéresse
au sujet il s'en est emparé sur la
surconsommation qui est liée aux usages
du numérique vous allez publier à la fin
de l'année 2023 une édition de la
collecte des données et qui inclut pour
la première fois l'empreinte
environnementale des acteurs du
numérique est-ce que vous pouvez nous en
dire un petit peu plus pour nous donner
quelques éléments sur les données qui
sont déjà collectées vos préconisations
vous m'excuserez madame mais je ne peux
pas attendre votre réponse mais je la
verrai bien entendu en vidéo
merci
Florence blatrix compta et ensuite Serge
Mériot merci madame la présidente madame
la Présidente je souhaiterais revenir
sur la question posée par ma collègue
Anne-Catherine concernant la
contribution des des gros
des opérateurs des gros consommateurs de
données on pense en particulier au gafam
le commissaire Thierry Breton si Eddy
favorable vous avez évoqué la prochaine
consultation publique mais j'ai cru
comprendre que le Conseil des
régulateurs européens était relativement
réservés sur le sujet vous avez évoqué
la responsabilité de votre volonté de
responsabiliser ces acteurs mais quels
sont de manière un peu plus concrète vos
pistes pour les responsabilités et selon
vous la bonne méthode pour faire
contribuer les gars femme au
développement de ces infrastructures
numériques sans risquer en particulier
de porter atteinte à la neutralité du
Net et voilà c'est bien le la difficulté
autre question une question sur le
concernant le règlement des données data
acte qui est actuellement en discussion
au niveau européen visant à favoriser le
partage et la circulation des données
et donc ce texte dispose que les
fournisseurs de produits numériques
notamment les assistants vocaux seraient
tenus de rendre accessibles les données
générées par leur utilisation aux
utilisateurs et éventuellement aux
tierces aux entreprises tierces et le
texte poserait également des obligations
internes d'interopérabilité la France
souhaite en outre inclure dans le champ
de ce règlement les smattes les
smartphones et donc ma question est la
suivante des obligations de partage
poser par le futur data acte
pourrait-elle selon vous faciliter un
diagnostic objectifé sur l'accès
Internet depuis les terminaux mobiles et
à terme favorisés un meilleur accès à un
Internet ouvert depuis ces terminaux
et enfin une dernière question sur la
sur la boussole numérique qui a été
publiée le 19 décembre dernier dans la
dans une résolution du 22 juillet
dernier on invitait le Sénat invitait à
élargir l'objectif initial de couverture
de toutes les zones habitées par la 5G
par des objectifs de qualité de service
conformément aux principes de neutralité
technologique cette précie cette
préconisation a été partiellement
reprise dans le texte final qui évoque
des réseaux sans fil
à haut débit de nouvelles générations
dont les performantes sont au moins
équivalentes à celle de la 5G donc que
pensez-vous de cet objectif au vu des
réalités du territoire français et de
l'actuel déploiement de la 5G
merci
Florent Serge Mérillou
pardon pour lier pour remédier aux
nombreux défauts liés au raccordement à
la fibre par sous-traitance en Syrie moi
je n'en demandais département on arrive
à noter jusqu'à 5 opérateurs en Série 5
sous-traitants donc voyez ce qui reste
pour celui qui fait réellement le
travail quoi les
c'est ce que vous appelez le mode stock
les acteurs de la filière et notamment
et les opérateurs d'infrastructures se
sont engagés à respecter un nouveau mode
stock dit stock V2
et donc à présent la sous-traitance de
ces opérations de rocade de raccordement
est limité normalement à deux
prestataires ce qui est censé corriger
les irrégularités d'installation que
collectivités et usagée ont trop souvent
vécu moi j'ai dit je vois des fibres des
des câbles qui sont accrochés aux
branches déjà non mais au branche des
arbres en bordure de route quoi donc
alors quand un arbre tombe ben voilà on
refait comme les photos téléphoniques
c'est le maire qui vient remettre un
poteau bon
[Rires]
et partout dans le territoire malgré la
bonne volonté des acteurs c'est défauts
d'installation persistent
donc plus d'un an après l'instauration
du mode stock V2 quel est votre position
vis-à-vis de ces difficultés comment les
expliquer vous puisqu'on a l'impression
que rien n'a changé et la question c'est
aussi le coût de la prestation de
raccordement est-elle par exemple
serait-elle par exemple sous-évaluée
merci Madame merci Serge Viviane
Artigalas à côté de Serge merci madame
la présidente madame la Présidente oui
vous avez annoncé à faire on sait tous
que la fermeture du réseau cuivre va se
faire progressivement et que des phases
d'expérimentation sont prévues dans mon
département les Hautes-Pyrénées ce sont
dans le lot de 21 communes qui sont qui
sont touchées j'ai reçu le délégué
territorial d'Orange qui m'a expliqué un
petit peu dit qu'ils étaient les
communes et qu'il allait faire le tour
de ses communes moi je me pose quand
même des questions sur les solutions
d'accompagnement qui sont prévus pour
citoyens fortement dépendants de ce
réseau cuivre via par exemple la
téléassistance c'est un changement
majeur pour eux et je n'ai pas vu des
mesures d'accompagnement est-ce que les
opérateurs sont tenus d'accompagner
quand ça va s'arrêter et qu'ils vont
devoir migrer vers d'autres solutions
celles aussi prévue pour les personnes
les moins à l'aise dans l'usage des
outils numériques et la migration de
leurs services vers un abonnement
similaire sur une ligne fibre là aussi
on sait très bien que si on n'a pas des
personnes qui accompagnent certaines de
nos concitoyens dans cette migration ça
sera très très difficile pour eux le box
changé une box c'est une autre n'est pas
simple et puis en fin c'est le prévu
pour les élus locaux parce que ils sont
souvent en première ligne dans ce type
de problématique il devront parfois
nécessairement jouer un rôle de
médiateur y compris dans le cadre d'un
refus de particulier ce qui risque
d'arriver donc quel est vous en tant que
régulateur vous obligez les opérateurs à
faire à faire ce type d'accompagnement
et particulièrement pour les élus locaux
j'insiste
merci beaucoup à votre contenu je
demande à mes collègues d'être le plus
bref possible parce que la liste est
très longue Sylviane Noël ensuite
Jean-Marc Boyer merci madame la
présidente madame la Présidente lors de
son audition madame Christelle Hedman a
indiqué s'agissant de la hausse des
tarifs de gros je cite que l'Arcep n'a
rien fait alors que tout était prévu
annoncé dans la précédente analyse de
marché nous nous préparons à introduire
de lourds contentieux contre les
décisions de la recette de ne pas avoir
revu le tarif de dégroupage il ne s'agit
pas de défendre une prétendurante il
s'agit de défendre la qualité de service
à laquelle nos concitoyens ont droit fin
de citation ma question est la suivante
qu'est-ce qui fait précisément litige
entre Orange et vous sur le niveau du
tarif de dégroupage pourquoi n'avez-vous
pas engagé la révision du temps de
dégroupage en 2022 comme vous y étiez
engagé lors de la présentation par
Orange d'un plan de fermeture de son
réseau cuivre et par ailleurs madame
Hedman avait indiqué également j'avais
beaucoup investi pour mettre à niveau
quand il y a des problèmes de qualité
certains de nos concurrents ont aussi
beaucoup à faire sur leurs
infrastructures c'est au régulateur de
faire le suivi fin de citation est-ce
que selon vous les plans de reprise
proposées par les opérateurs vous
paraissent suffisamment ambitieux et
cohérent compte tenu de l'état de
dégradation et de défaillance constatées
sur ces réseaux y a-t-il d'autres
réseaux qui ont des problèmes
structurels de qualité de service et qui
n'ont pas encore proposé de plan de
reprise de leur réseau et enfin comment
la recette va assurer que les opérateurs
mettront rapidement en oeuvre ces plans
au vu des enjeux merci
merci
Jean-Marc Boyer ensuite Micheline
Jacques merci madame la Présidente en
attendant l'arrivée de la fibre des
demandeurs de création de nouvelles
lignes cuivre soit refusé l'installation
par Orange alors que le déploiement de
la fibre est annoncé cet élément est
important quand il impacte de
décomissionnement de cuivre qui est
entamé et pour lequel l'ARCEP joue un
rôle majeur et je partage aussi comme
mes collègues le constat de l'abandon de
l'entretien du réseau actuel alors
quelle est la règle établie par la
recette quel rôle joue l'accepte
quel rôle l'accepte envisage pour les
collectivités locales en particulier
pour les Mairies et pourquoi certains
territoires aujourd'hui sont oubliés non
fibrés cerné par des territoires eux
fibrés pour qu'elle justification j'ai
des exemples et des élus n'ont aucune
explication
merci Jean-Marc Micheline Jacques merci
madame la présidente madame la
Présidente lors de son audition madame
Christelle Edman donc directrice
générale du groupe Orange a indiqué que
la modélisation tarifaire décidée par
l'Arsène en 2020 ne prend pas en compte
tous les éléments du réseau ce qui
conduit à la sous-évaluation du tarif de
découvrir groupage comment expliquer vos
corrompre indique ne pas avoir la
capacité de recouvrer ses coûts avec le
nouveau modèle tarifaire défini par
l'ARCEP les conclusions du rapport du
comité d'évaluation du plan France au
débit précise que les aides publiques
ont été mobilisées pour les territoires
ultramarins au même niveau que pour le
reste du territoire elle souligne que la
couverture fibre malgré une belle
progression de 63% à la Réunion et 48% à
Saint-Martin reste très inégalitaire et
sous déployé dans les autres territoires
le taux de couverture variant de 36% à
Saint-Barthélémy à 0% à Mayotte et la
sous-évaluation du tarif de découpage
indiqué par Orange ne risque-t-elle pas
de freiner le déploiement de la fibre
dans ces territoires et de compromettre
l'objectif de généralisation de la fibre
à l'horizon 2025 fixé par le
gouvernement et enfin j'ai constaté un
écart du tarif de des groupages de 2,5
euros avec l'Allemagne comment
l'expliquer vous
merci Micheline Martine Berthet de
savoir merci madame la Présidente
effectivement de sa voix donc voilà
ce recours ma question madame la
Présidente j'ai deux questions le rythme
du déploiement est un point important
pour nos collectivités territoriales nos
entreprises et nos concitoyens mais la
qualité peut poser problème en observe
trop souvent que le déploiement se fait
en aérien pour aller vite au détriment
de la qualité et de la résilience quel
regard avez-vous sur ce point le
déploiement de la fibre est un objectif
majeur pour Orange mais l'entretien ou
la fermeture du cuivre doit être réalisé
en simultané donc plus de coûts et moins
de recettes cela questionne sur les
moyens avec lesquels les réaliser pour
notre opérateur historique qui investit
mais voit d'autres opérateurs
commerciaux en recueillir les bénéfices
merci
donc va-t-on en rester au stade du
dialogue ou de la simple mise en demeure
ou bien envisagez-vous de réelles
sanctions pour ces retards dans le
déploiement de la fibre au mépris des
engagements pris par les opérateurs
franchement
merci madame la Présidente pour votre
présentation
sur le le devenir du réseau tn et votre
prédécesseur monsieur Soriano
considérait que ce réseau est à bout de
souffle mais il ne voulait pas que les
fréquences TNT soient attribuées aux
opérateurs
quel est
ou quels sont madame vos positions
relatives au devenir de la TNT
à l'utilisation éventuelle de la de la
bande de la 470 694 mégahertz
et en particulier pour du très haut
débit
le Très Haut Débit hertzien certains
l'appellent très haut débit numérique
pourrait permettre entre autres
objectifs de connecter au très haut
débit donc des foyers non facilement
raccordables au FTTH c'est souvent le
cas dans le rural diffus et en situation
isolée donc cette question derrière
cette question entre autres sujets il y
a la fin du réseau du réseau cuivre qui
sera problématique pour les foyers non
connectables à la fibre optique voilà
donc je voudrais savoir quel est votre
doctrine ou vos réflexions en la matière
je crois que vous êtes déjà exprimé
publiquement là-dessus ça serait
intéressant de que vous nous précisiez
les choses merci merci beaucoup Franck
Daniel grimillet qui est parti oui merci
madame la Présidente je voudrais me
permettre juste d'insister madame la
Présidente sur le mode stock qui
vraiment démontrer ses limites des
territoires entiers qui qui ont joué le
jeu de la fibre en investissant de façon
majeure et qui ne peuvent pas être
malheureusement les boucs émissaires de
tout un tas d'abonnés qui se retrouvent
débranchés on le sait très bien la
technique qui consiste à débrancher
quelqu'un pour brancher quelqu'un
d'autre et qui se retrouve dans un
désarroi total notamment en territoire
ruraux donc vraiment je me permets
d'insister sur les limites de l'exercice
malheureusement je crois que ça ne
concerne pas que les territoires ruraux
Daniel grimillet pardon et enfin on
finira par Françoise Ferrat oui merci
Madame présidente ça tombe bien parce
que je prolonge l'intervention notre
colonne Anne la région Grand Est fait le
choix effectivement de faire un
investissement et de raccorder
l'ensemble des concitoyens à la fibre et
on assiste à du gâchis parce
qu'effectivement la qualité des
intervenants pour les opérateurs et ça a
été évoqué par plusieurs sous la
sous-traitance mais à mal effectivement
ce déploiement énorme et ses moyens
financiers il y a un vrai souci là au
niveau des opérateurs pire que ça je
voudrais vous alerter sur le fait qu'on
a mis beaucoup de moyens mais que
parfois la qualité du travail diminue la
qualité en fait de la capacité de la
Philippe telle qu'elle était envisagée
première question et deuxième question
là aussi il y a un souci pour le futur
la fin du cuivre
comment ça va se passer pour les
transports et notamment les poteaux qui
va entretenir les poteaux par rapport au
support puisqu'on sait qu'aujourd'hui la
plupart des supports sont des supports
cuivre
merci beaucoup Daniel et pour terminer
Françoise Ferrat merci madame la
Présidente ma question vient au
poursuite de celle posée par mon
collègue Fabien gay si j'en crois la
lecture de la presse justement ce petit
monde est un peu en émoi et haute
tension si j'ai bien lu
s'agissons du fait que les ventes
baisses globalement de 10% par an et que
le prix du papier ça détournerait
personne à augmenter de 40 %. dans
l'urgence le gouvernement s'apprête à
débloquer 30 millions d'euros pour venir
en aide à la distribution des titres
madame la Présidente si les pouvoirs
publics ne changent pas leur répartition
cette aide sera comme toujours versé
exclusivement à la presse quotidienne
nationale ou plus exactement à France
messagerie le concurrent les MLP
précisément qui représente 550 éditeurs
et distribue près de 3000 titres ne
touchera rien
rien
madame la Présidente pouvez-vous nous
faire connaître votre position votre
sentiment sur ce point
merci Françoise et madame à présent j'ai
une toute petite question presque de
néophyte lors d'un déplacement en
Californie notre commission est allée
visiter Space X et donc on nous a
beaucoup parlé au passage en nous
prenant un peu en otage de du
développement de Starlink des
communications au travers voilà de la
constellation d'elenmosk quel est le
rôle de la recette sur la voilà les
télécommunications par satellite et en
particulier voilà de Starlink voilà
c'est vraiment une question
je mesure aujourd'hui en fait ce que ça
fait d'avoir autant de questions d'un
coup
parce que si je peux faire une
confidence c'est finalement la première
fois que je suis auditionnée devant une
commission de permanente depuis ma
nomination comme présidente il y a
peut-être eu la commission du
développement durable juste après ma
nomination mais voilà donc merci
beaucoup pour toutes ces questions qui
montrent l'intérêt que vous avez au
sujet que porte la recette et c'est vrai
que ça touche le quotidien des Français
alors je vais commencer par la presse
parce que j'en ai pas parlé dans mes
propos liminaires j'avais prévu dans
d'en parler mais comme les propos de
madame la Présidente étaient axées sur
la peau et Telecom voilà pour récourcir
les propos liminaires j'avais pas parlé
donc vous me suivez vous m'avez d'abord
parlé de la poste donc j'ai un mot sur
la poste
sur la mission d'égalité républicaine et
sur le fait qu'on est très vigilant
aussi à ce sur ce sujet d'abord pour
faire respecter des obligations qui sont
celles de la Poste au titre des services
universels obligations qui sont fixées
par la loi donc voilà c'est ça c'est
c'est sûr et donc nous avons dans notre
avis en fait concernant la
renouvellement de la gamme tarifaire de
la Poste insister sur l'accompagnement
nécessaire et notamment de la compaction
nécessaire sur la illette rouge et
trouver une solution pour que
l'ensemble des citoyens puissent
utiliser cette lettre rouge qu'ils aient
ou non accès à Internet
le concernant la distribution de la
presse par la poste
il y a une obligation de tourner
quotidienne donc il y a voilà ça il y a
une continuité et si jamais c'est pas le
cas et si jamais il y a des difficultés
de qualité de service sur ce sujet-là
nous demanderons des comptes
naturellement à la à la poste c'est
feront respecter les obligations
au titre de la mission de service
universel de la poste
après le choix revient à l'éditeur de
savoir si par la poste aussi passe par
un distributeur privé
concernant
l'autre question sur
sur la sur la presse sur la
oui pardon
madame la sénatrice vous m'avez posé la
question de des subventions accordées à
la presse alors ce sont des subversions
qui sont versées aux éditeurs
ce sont toujours des subventions qui
sont versées aux éditeurs
nous avons un regard nous avons la
mission d'évaluer les
surcoûts que supportent France
messagerie dans le cas de la
distribution de la presse quotidienne
notre mission est une mission
d'évaluation
nous ne rentrons pas en fait dans la
façon dont est financé France messagerie
pour autant nous sommes extrêmement et
nous l'avons dit dans nos dans nos avis
malgré la hausse des tarifs par France
messagerie l'équilibre de France
messagerie nous paraît fragile
c'est un message important étant donné
la mission d'intérêt général que
porte-france messagerie dans la
dipribution de la presse quotidienne
papier auprès de tous les marchands
journaux de France donc je permets
d'alerter sur ce sujet la représentation
nationale puisque j'en ai j'en ai
l'occasion
concernant la question de SpaceX madame
la Présidente notre rôle
sur Starling c'est l'attribution des
fréquences pour les stations terriennes
Voilà il se trouve que la France
Attestation terriennes pour vis-à-vis
des satellites parce que on a une place
en Europe qui est assez idéale pour
couvrir après la couverture européenne
par par les satellites stèles sterling
nous avons eu pas mal d'échanges en fait
sur les constellations satellitaires au
sein du collège parce qu'on voit une
multiplication de ces constellations et
de lancement de ces constellations les
unes en concurrence avec les autres mais
ce qui fait quand même beaucoup beaucoup
de satellites dans l'espace et donc nous
allons faire un atelier une réflexion au
cours de cette année sur l'empreinte
environnementale que génère la
multiplication de ces
de ces constellations donc voilà c'était
un point un pied de côté par rapport à
votre question mais qui est pour nous
quand même une un sujet d'attention de
voir comment on peut à l'avenir
maîtriser aussi l'empreinte
environnementale du lancement de ces
constellations beaucoup de questions ont
été posées sur la qualité de service de
la fibre sur le mode stock
juste un mot sur le mode stock
c'est pas le mode stock en lui qui pose
un problème pour moi c'est les problèmes
c'est la difficulté qu'on a c'est qu'il
y a pas eu de mise en place de processus
de contrôle par les opérateurs entre eux
dans les opérations stocks donc ce sont
des problèmes opérationnels parce que le
mode stock lui-même a permis en fait
l'engagement des opérateurs commerciaux
à commercialiser la fibre et si
aujourd'hui on a plus de 50% des abonnés
français qui sont sur la fibre et avec
sur les réseaux fibrés souvent au bout
d'un ou deux ans on a 70 à 80% de taux
de
raccordement par rapport à ce qui
existait avant le cuivre c'est sans
doute grâce au mode stock à la
motivation qu'on les opérateurs
commerciaux en revanche je n'ai pas les
problèmes et je le dis pas j'ai dit que
c'était ma première priorité en arrivant
donc ce qu'on est c'est attaché à faire
c'est que c'est que les opérateurs
mettent bien en place les processus
quelque chose de contrôle donc ils ont
développé de nouveaux outils
au compte rendu d'intervention qui
faisait ils y rajoutent des photos des
photos qui sont analysées par des
algorithmes
pour permettre de repérer s'il y a des
défauts et deuxièmement ils ont déployé
mais ça c'est depuis très récemment
de peur entre septembre et la fin de
cette année un outil qui s'appelle lit
intervention pour que on sache quel
opérateur intervient à quel moment sur
le réseau donc pour avoir une
traçabilité de qui fait quoi
l'exploitation de l'ensemble de ces
informations par les opérateurs
d'infrastructures et par les opérateurs
commerciaux dans leurs échanges vont
permettre de déterminer en fait qu'elles
sont qui qui pratiquent les malfaçons
pour pouvoir après appliquer des
sanctions dans les contrats alors
pourquoi ça pas encore d'effets sur le
terrain et vous le voyez pas encore
aujourd'hui
c'est parce que c'est quand même encore
très très très récent à cela on a
demandé aux opérateurs et à leur
sous-traitants de former correctement
leurs agents d'intervention et que il y
ait un label de mis en place sur les
agents d'intervention la joie dire que
ça avance plus lentement mais nous
sommes très attachés à ce que les
opérateurs et leur sous-traitants
avancent sur ce sujet et troisième axe
qui a été mis en place et qui se décline
actuellement c'est une reprise en fait
de tous les malfaçons qui existent sur
tous les réseaux au fil de l'eau et donc
ça ça veut dire que quand vous avez en
fait une armoire de rue qui est tout
emmêlée l'agent d'intervention il a du
mal à travailler correctement et si vous
allez voir ça sur le terrain on comprend
les difficultés que même peuvent
rencontrer à raccorder et donc il faut
que l'opérateur d'infrastructure qui a
mis en place ces armoires
proposent en fait aux opérateurs
commerciaux des armoires de rue qui soit
propre rangées et ça nécessite des
reprises régulières de l'ensemble des
malfaçons et à côté de ça on a des
réseaux particulièrement accidentogènes
et là il y a une question supplée
supplémentaire est-ce que on estime que
les remises les plans de reprise de ces
réseaux très accidentogène sont
suffisants
je veux dire on va faire le suivi ce que
nous ont présenté les opérateurs c'est
des plans de reprise complète de leur
réseau donc
naturellement
le plan de point de mutualisation donc
l'armoire de rue mais aussi derrière
tout le réseau derrière toutes les
la ligne optique mais tous les tout
enfin tout le réseau qui est derrière
les points de branchement aussi et
derrière les points de branchement si
nécessaire donc on a eu deux plans de
reprise pour l'instant que je vous ai
mentionné en introduction et nous avons
reçu parce qu'il y a un autre réseau qui
est il y a d'autres réseaux qui sont
concernés mais qui concernent beaucoup
moins de lignes ce sont des réseaux de
Free en région parisienne donc
Sarcelles par exemple et dans d'autres
communes ou
free vient hier exactement de nous
envoyer leur plan de reprise notifié
leur pôle entreprise donc
avec ça on espère que sur ces réseaux
accidentogènes qui concentre en fait
une grande majorité des incidents
on aura des améliorations courantes 2023
une question qui est liée à la qualité
de service du film de la fibre
concerne la rémunération des
sous-traitants pour nous c'est assez
clair c'est au grand donneur d'ordre
d'assurer une rémunération suffisante
des agents d'intervention et notamment
par rapport aux exigences de qualité de
service que nous attendons et nous avons
rappelé aux opérateurs l'importance de
rémunérer correctement les agents
d'intervention sur le filaire non
seulement pour que les personnes
recrutées
est une formation suffisante mais aussi
pour que la filière continue à attirer
des agents enfin des personnes pour
réaliser le travail aujourd'hui il
manque de 2000 à 3000 personnes sur le
terrain sur la filière des services de
télécommunication et c'est un enjeu en
fait de rendre cette filière attrayante
et c'est l'objectif enfin et je dirais
c'est la responsabilité des donneurs
d'ordre
de le faire je à l'occasion quand même
je voudrais saluer la renégociation qui
a pu avoir orange avec les
sous-traitants en octobre et novembre et
c'est important parce que Orange est
quand même le premier donneur d'ordre du
secteur
sur les déploiements des zonami et ça a
été cité sur sur plusieurs communes sur
les obligations de complétude
on a mis en demeure orange de respecter
leurs obligations auxonami ils ont
contesté
cette mise en demeure devant le Conseil
d'État c'est ce que j'ai dit en
introduction
mais et donc pour l'instant on instruit
naturellement les objectifs liés à notre
mise en demeure mais
mon objectif naturellement c'est que
l'ensemble de ces réseaux et l'ensemble
de ces obligations soit respecté pour
revenir à une question plus générale
vraiment plus générale qui a été posée
par madame la Présidente en introduction
de savoir
comment on travaille avec les opérateurs
et comment on fait respecter les
obligations des opérateurs
on cherche toujours le meilleur moyen
pour avoir des résultats vraiment on a
pensé par exemple sur le mode socle que
le meilleur moyen c'était de travailler
avec ces opérateurs pour qu'ils mettent
en place les processus de contrôle pour
qu'ils se rendent compte et qu'il soit
plus dans le déni de la situation et par
rapport aussi aux outils qu'on peut
avoir sur les obligations de complétude
on met en demeure très régulièrement les
opérateurs de
les opérateurs de respecter leurs
obligations et
on aura enfin la formation
ou les formations correspondantes
n'auront
aucun état d'âme j'irai à faire
respecter les obligations et aller plus
loin si nécessaire
j'essaie de retrouver toutes les
questions auxquelles j'ai pas
il y a eu plusieurs questions aussi sur
l'environnement
concernant le retour d'expérience
typiquement de notre première Colette de
données sur pour de l'enquête annuelle
que nous réalisons sur la collecte de
données nous l'avons fait auprès des
opérateurs en 2020 et 2020 en 2021 et
2022 et nous avons restitué des
informations
montrant typiquement que ce qu'on a pu
collecter comme information nous a donné
comme renseignement que le réseau fibre
consommé quatre fois moins d'énergie que
par abonnés que le réseau cuivre que les
réseaux mobiles consommaient deux fois
plus
d'énergie que les réseaux WiFi et donc
ça nous a permis de sortir
une liste de bonnes pratiques que nous
avons mis en ligne sur internet pour
tous les citoyens de savoir quels sont
les bons usages en fait pour limiter
l'emprunt environnement du numérique ça
donne en plus du crédit la démarche de
fermeture du réseau cuivre que l'ARCEP
accompagne non seulement pour des
raisons économiques parce que ça serait
stupide de garder deux réseaux en
parallèle l'économiquement mais aussi
pour des raisons environnementales
puisque le nouveau réseau fibre et
beaucoup beaucoup plus soft sobre d'un
point de vue énergétique que le réseau
cuivre précédent
il y a
sur la maintenance et puis je vais
revenir sur le tarif de découpage sur la
maintenance des poteaux oui sur
le propriétaire du génie civil
aujourd'hui est orange et il a des
obligations de remplacer les poteaux
alors souvent à la demande des
opérateurs d'infrastructures mais il a
l'obligation de remplacer les poteaux
dans le cadre de la nouvelle analyse de
marché on regarde si on peut pas
renforcer cette obligation
et ce qui est important pour nous aussi
c'est que
cette
obligations liées au génie civiles
d'orange ont été détachés finalement des
obligations qui sont liées au réseau
cuivre dans le cadre de notre analyse de
marché donc ces obligations pourront
perdurer après la fermeture du réseau
cuivre ce qui est
ce qui est important voilà
il en aura l'obligation il en aura
l'obligation c'est ce que j'explique
c'est à dire que nous avons séparé
préalablement à l'analyse de marché de
2020 l'ensemble des sujets était lié au
sein d'une même analyse de marché qui a
été sur le réseau cuir et en 2020 ça je
mens la recette a séparé les deux sujets
en disant il y a des obligations de
génie civil d'orange et on travaille
actuellement sur la prochaine analyse de
marché donc on est en train de d'étudier
ça et puis il y a des obligations qui
sont liées au réseau cuivre donc une
fois qu'il y aura plus de cuivre les
obligations liées au génie civil
d'orange seront maintenues
n'hésitez pas dans ce cas-là à me
signaler des sujets pour qu'on le pour
qu'on leur signale bien évidemment je
suis pas naïve c'est à dire que quand je
vous ai dit mon attention particulière
aux enjeux de qualité de service sur les
réseaux cuivre ça intégré aussi la
qualité sur les sur le génie civil et la
qualité sur le génie civil et j'ai
personnellement demandé au service la
semaine dernière de vérifier comment
dans la prochaine analyse de marché on
pourrait regarder ça de façon plus fin
et de façon plus voilà donc on a bien
cette ce souci en tête et cette
réflexion en tête
sur le tarif du dégroupage je crois que
j'ai j'ai dit en propos introductif ce
que je pouvais dire ce que ce que ce que
j'ai rappelé c'est que les revenus
d'orange au titre du réseau cuivre la
boucle locale cuivre c'est 2 milliards
d'euros
on a
ils nous ont saisi en octobre 2022 d'une
demande de révision de tarif de
dégroupage qu'on a examiné on a trouvé
légitime une des demandes celle qu'il y
a à y faire
et on a mis en consultation publique en
décembre donc rapidement cette
proposition et après ça va continuer son
cours vous savez que on doit notifier à
la Commission européenne des décisions
qu'on prendrait éventuellement à ce
sujet bon orange a attaqué leur cèpes la
décision de l'ARCEP sur le tarif de des
groupages devant le Conseil d'État et je
peux pas vraiment en dire plus
maintenant
quelles sont les questions sur
l'outre-mer je crois
[Musique]
alors sur sur l'autre mère c'est vrai
que les territoires ultramarins sauf la
Réunion la réunion était un des premiers
départements fibrés en France mais les
autres
départements outre-mer sont un petit peu
en décalage par rapport à la moyenne des
départements français dans tous les
départements d'outre-mer sauf à je crois
à Mayotte
il y a des projets de déploiement de la
fibre mais qui sont portés comme comme
partout en fait en France par les
collectivités donc s'il y a des
problèmes spécifiques je pense que il
faut aussi que vous regardiez ces
paliers à la régulation que la recette
met en place je pense pas c'est plus des
sujets à voir avec la NCT
et les collectivités et en concertation
avec les collectivités concernées bien
sûr sur la TNT
ce que je sais c'est qu'on doit
que la décision finale s'appliquera qu'à
partir de 2030 sur cette bande et que
pour l'instant tous les jeux sont
ouverts c'est-à-dire que on doit
orienter prendre la décision finale en
2025 pour une application en 2030 c'est
ça je me retourne vers Olivier
voilà donc il y a un point d'étape en
2025 sur ce sujet donc peut-être une
nouvelle orientation d'affectation de la
banque ou pas en 2025 moi ce que je
souhaite c'est que l'analyse de la
situation prenant en compte les besoins
de chacun des secteurs soient fait de
façon objective entre les besoins des
télécommunications et les besoins de
l'audiovisuel
pour savoir comment gérer au mieux et
comment à qui attribuer à qui affecter
en fait cette bande de fréquence
l'attribution sera faite en 2030
le raccordement à l'accès au tri au
début la situation des idées
ça rejoint ça rejoint une autre une
autre question que qui m'a été posée en
fait sur les solutions alternatives la
5G et tout ça
l'objectif qui a pris la France dans le
cadre du plan français des billes et de
déployer la fibre partout d'ici 2020
et donc et donc sauf cas d'exception et
peut y avoir des et il peut il peut y
avoir des exceptions je sais pas ce que
vous appelez beaucoup mais ça c'est un
travail qui est en
qui est devant nous mais moi les
situations que j'entends difficiles
exceptionnel et ça veut pas non plus
dire que il y aura pas la fibre à terme
c'est de l'ordre de 1 à 2% voilà
c'est ce qui me c'est ce qui me remonte
en fait des des
remontées des opérateurs et des
remontées c'est dans non non c'est pas
une moyenne c'est pas une moyenne
nationale c'est une moyenne sur les
réseaux d'initiatives publiques pour
autant
les solutions alternatives seront
nécessairement mobilisés
notamment si au moment de la fermeture
du réseau cuivre il y a durablement pas
la fibre et que Louis loïde l'opérateur
d'infrastructure a une bonne raison pour
le faire
quelquefois c'est aussi vous savez des
raisons qui sont liées au fait que le
propriétaire privé ne veut pas faire les
travaux chez lui et donc qui préfère une
solution alternative et que dans ce
cas-là on va pas la fibre ne va pas
desservir ce localab puisque on va
amener la fibre à ce locala que s'il y a
une demande en fait derrière le point de
branchement le raccordement final est
fait que s'il y a une demande
naturellement sur sur le local donc ici
des cas où c'est des choix privés mais
oui il y aura ponctuellement
mobilisation de technologie alternative
alors ça peut être la 5G ça peut être
la 4G plus ça peut être voilà d'autres
technologies
et le satellite aussi bien sûr
sur la
un des facteurs clés de succès pour moi
c'est ce que j'ai dit vraiment c'est la
gouvernance et la concertation et la
gouvernance et la constatation avec les
collectivités locales et j'aimerais même
que les collectivités locales qu'ils le
veulent puis jouer un rôle plus
important aujourd'hui dans le choix des
communes fait par Orange parce que il y
a des communes qui sont très motivées
moi j'ai des élus qui m'écrivent
notamment des présidents de départements
qui m'écrivent pour me dire on a fibré
partout on veut plus de communes dans
les lots de fermeture et pour autant
aujourd'hui orange ne fait pas sa
sélection de de cette façon là et sur
les accompagnements des citoyens oui il
faut il faut de l'accompagnement citoyen
bien évidemment à la fois par les
opérateurs mais certainement aussi par
de l'action publique
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente pour
l'ensemble de ces réponses je pense
qu'on aura l'occasion de se revoir
peut-être un peu plus rapidement voilà
que cette fois-ci pour traiter des
points particuliers merci en tout cas
merci infiniment